foreign
[Music]
feel that
tell me that doesn't feel like a [ __ ]
[Music]
Calvin
me human
communicate big man
no play
no
you're not students
you're not kids anymore unfortunately
[Music]
your X-Men yeah let's go
I think you should go home now Kevin
there's nothing going for sure
get back on San Vicente take it to the
gym then switch over to the 405 North
and let it dump you out into Mulholland
where you blocked foreign
[Applause]
who is he
does this hurt
don't be a [ __ ]
okay good night Bob good night golden
jet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
suck my dick Jesus suck my dick
that's my dick I'm not joking
suck it
I'm not
do it wait pick up bro
all right all right all right all right
all right sorry sorry
I'm not kidding Joe
you're coming into the back door grab
the children save it
[ __ ] you
I haven't kissed you in 10 years yeah I
know
it feels as lame as last time something
happened up here what am I supposed to
do Bob how do I get your attention make
a bird call Go Go
[Applause]
come on Google
God damn I knew that was gonna break
she'll muffed you up again
Ah that's really creative oopsie dope
see I muffed it up
how do you know my mother was an
egyptologist
you [ __ ] [ __ ] all just receive it
yeah
[ __ ] my pants on camera
check
I'm sorry I wasn't ready I didn't hear
action
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
God damn it
never find any person in this room
except the car oh no except for come
raise the band he's old he's useless
he's just that good to me
you gotta go for real you gotta got them
I told my wife Beverly
when I was on top of her
what don't [ __ ] don't laugh when
I was on top of her
making intense painful love
you
know I know you're gay how you waxed
your anus
you know how I know your game how you
waxed my anus
what is a human kite it's that thing
where you tie a string to a [ __ ] and a
windbreaker
and then run through a field
touch that okay we're good we're good
we're good Dimitri you're really growing
into this uh
please call cut David please I'm begging
you you know how I know that you're gay
oh
my my dick feels good
well it seems like a rush boy that
doesn't have a such a new bottle
[Music]
don't keep putting your dick on me man
that's not my dick
that's a mic pack no it's not
I had to go to a specialist to get my
hips realigned very painful the doctor
said it was similar to uh
operating on a German Shepherd uh when
they have uh hip dysplasia
[Music]
I'm not as professional I can't do this
right now
[Laughter]
medium coffee cream Two Sugars
Heaven wept in my mouth wow who put a
flavor grenade in my mouth
pull the pin whoa piping hot oh scalding
30 creepers hottest beverage ever going
straight to the hospital are you the new
guidance counselor can I help you yes I
have a problem I have what can only be
described as an enormous boner
I'm having a problem I have we can only
be described oh
yes
can I help you yes I'm having a problem
I have an enormous border
[ __ ] okay we gotta do this George I'll
put it in George
I'm gonna get up on you oh I'm gonna get
up on your bones hmm
maybe I could just scrape my dick on you
just
I'm gonna get I want to squeeze out some
of that
some of the juice what
oh God
[Music]
so far
don't stop until it's over
I'll show you
oh so now I'm too skinny
I don't want nothing yet
okay well me and my phone
is this what you want
is it right
Can You Escape for your phone
if I put on a few pounds
we'll be able to fight for you
long enough to sleep
that'll be five thousand dollars good
day to you both
what the hell was that
we misplaced your baby
[Applause]
that's [ __ ] right you took my [ __ ]
steamy what's up come on let's get in
the fountain right now all my jokes go
ahead you clean me
clean me in the fountain right now give
you a little slash
I want my baby back baby baby baby I
want my baby back baby baby
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you getting a little Tookie down there
sorry about that Mama
[Applause]
thank you
I can't think of a legal reason to
punish you for leaving your grandmother
at a nuclear power play but you are
going straight to hell for that part is
adjourned
come on
it's impossible
oh
10 to the Dozen if you want a battle of
humor
oh I'm finding this so funny well I'm
not
okay you know sarcasm
[Music]
finding this so funny
oh